greetings from podcast Ville it's Monday
October something I don't know what it
is twenty-something the Church of what's
happening now is brought to you by my
bookie whether you're in expect or
you're a rookie
you should be betting at my bookie you
pick a three-team parlay all right and
if they hit all three you could turn a
hundred Isles into six hundred miles and
there's a lot of action going on right
now you got World Series
you got Boop switch it was a fight on
Friday night you could bet to somebody
getting punched in the face you got
everything but my bookie is the one I
bet I know you'll be happy with all year
do me a favor log in to my bookie right
now and don't miss out on the last
opportunity to collect the biggest
industries bonus use promo code Church
and you'll forget your deposit matched
by a hundred percent you understand me
100% 100%
that's promo code Church my bookie you
play you win you get paid also the
church is brought to you by my favorite
on it listen I just got the shipment I
got my little bars I take it on the road
with me for protein bars I got my shroom
Tech in shroom tech sport I got my alpha
brain I go on these cycles for 30 days
and I get off it then I go on for 30
days that's how I live my life
my focus is there my clarity's there I'm
healthier than ever listen go to anicon
right now press enter ch ch you are CH
and get 10% off delivered to your house
on accom slash Church right there 10% to
live at the house kick this [ __ ]
mealy little Sunday night Monday more
than chat with my main dog George Perez
we're going to Cleveland this weekend
gonna have a good time so I figured we
get Jenny I got a few questions for you
and then you go do whatever the [ __ ] you
gotta go do you I'm saying I'm just
chillin my boy you know I just got back
from paramount I was hanging my homeboy
big sleeps and you know how I was
waiting for today dog I'm excited you
got a spot to land somewhere now I'm
gonna go hang out at the store after
this they got some open mics I'm gonna
try to get up you know you do in the
store a lot yeah we're doing the store
let's got you as a regular or
no right now I'm a development spot but
I still grind I do all the open mics if
other people are running shows I try to
jump on Sam triply always puts me up
Redman always puts me up and Rogan puts
me up sometimes when he's there you know
I'm just grinding making it the journey
that it is dog
so it's called developmental spot yeah
it's a development spot so right now
like all the shows that I ran at The
Comedy Store they put up two comedians
before the whole show we do five minutes
each then the show starts that's pretty
cool I notice that they're doing they're
giving people find like that like from
eight fifty five to nine yeah sure that
all the door guys get spots too so it's
cool it's amazing what you've done with
comedy a hot dog it's a trip like a
homie I was telling these fools they're
like how do you know Joey I was like I
met him at peppers 2002-2003 it was
somebody's room dog and you were out
there and it was just ridiculous crazy
it's been a crazy journey [ __ ] let me
ask you something I know you thought
about you watch the news and stuff like
this you know when this Cavanaugh
stoppable started coming up right first
we have the meat to movement mm-hmm
which it's it's you know empowering
people when it's pointed people have
done some [ __ ] crazy [ __ ] especially
in Hollywood yeah but then you have this
new movement and I and I appreciate it
all you know I'm not I'm a crazy [ __ ]
but I'm gonna meet or I'm saying you
dick suck whatever but yeah me too
people trick people don't like that
but then something happen a couple of
weeks ago with the Kavanagh say
Dominic's felt just like you yeah we
both made mistakes
we both did our time and we moved the
[ __ ] on and guess what
little by little we're turning your life
around was that right like I'm priests
but you're not involved in doing stupid
[ __ ] you take the energy that you
remember when you used to wake up thirty
years ago you awake and I'm thinking
about how you were gonna make 50
straight-up whether it's delivering a
bag of coke
burger on Athena shanks we checks the
gas cards back yeah it's crazy how
somebody could pop up from 30 years ago
they say well George Perez and Joey Diaz
did this to me yeah and so what do you
want to do about it now what do you want
what do you want to talk about now
people change yeah fondly that you
changed how do you know I'm 41 and we'll
use a different way [ __ ] live you and
I and the family of the church what
would you like it to what he would what
was George's world fun at 21 if I would
have seen you on the street I just live
but I will sup homie where the [ __ ] you
from this is shotgun big bad orange gang
like that was my high like like like
when I got introduced to another male it
always be like what's up homeboy there's
a shotgun were you from football like it
was just like that
what we doing for it when you were 21 I
was doing construction I was a cement
Mason I was finishing concrete I was
making dog I was making a thousand a
week rent was seven hundred a month I
had my own [ __ ] place I had my baby's
mom I had I had girlfriends in every job
site that I was at for like three months
cuz sometimes we would rent hotels and
[ __ ] [ __ ] at the bars so yeah a dog
no criminal when you were 20 oh yeah
like you know I got I got caught with
the gun I got caught at the knife I got
uh I already got a couple graffiti
charges and [ __ ] it's nice to be a
tagger before I was a gangster it's to
write on the freeways and [ __ ] how old
were you when you were tagging fifteen
fourteen and what do they do when they
catch attack [ __ ] they they give you
community service like clearly though
you gotta clean all that [ __ ] pay a fine
then like if you get caught again your
parents get in trouble it's it was it
was in you know what I mean dog it was
in and we were juvie to give a little
juvie hall nah I went to juvie hall but
like my mom and dad my my dad was like
[ __ ] leave her my mom was like hell
no my mom watched bad boys the week
before was like they're not doing that
to my son
I could have hung dog you know I mean
but my mom was like nah but I do I was
in the county like by nineteen already
you know I know what prison is like I
can't imagine what Julie's like Oh like
I never wasn't sure homey the rules are
different but I have just seen
documentaries I'm read a thousand books
on it yeah of people talking about juvy
and it does not your chant if you get
listen if you get put in the system
after you're 21 there's a percentage of
a chance of recidivism when you get put
in the system when you're 15 14 you
pretty much define the problem yeah
done you're done for years with other
kids so that just as crazy as you are
and these were kids that weren't
shooters nothing like that and these
were kids that would just make a cop
yeah don't give up I grew up with kids
that would smack a [ __ ] you know but
just because ku is far to be coolest
yeah like [ __ ] this car you know like if
you don't like today you hear about
these school shootings and stuff with
the kids showed signs yeah you know
[ __ ] being a little whacked up when I
was a kid let me taste him I knew her
[ __ ] to stay away from there
was a couple kids I went to school with
that dog that was just you know how do
they mind we're gonna grow up to be
murderers yeah but okay so how would I
use this the 70s or 80s
there's the 70s so like a dog like
describe this for me is like cuz you're
in [ __ ] Jersey or New York Jersey
you're in Jersey dog like are you
walking by Cubans we're like what
nationality like I've always wondered
like is every project the different
nationality gangs like okay the only
time I was really ever around gangs and
my mother had to try cleaner in the
Bronx Oh in the late 60s the gang a
[ __ ] thing was huge
hell yeah New York the Bronx it was huge
and my mother's dry cleaner was on Royal
the Royal javelin yeah sure yeah so my
mom had to give a piece every week they
were calling a mandatory that's
mandatory who would my mom
there was no drivers were all Japanese I
still remember their insignia it was
like a Chinese guy with a ponytail on
their backs and there huh they were
bikers without the motorcycles were like
okay like the Warriors did like the
Warriors see how the Warriors saw you in
New York that five boroughs filled with
gang because now years later when I
started just going to Harlem I can't lie
to you I heard about gangs but I never
saw him but was involved with them at
all okay
I heard about the ghetto boys at that
time the ghetto boys like in the early
in 68 I know about the world javelins
I'm like I don't know I can't remember
they all have like weird names and they
all ran three blocks the only way I
think they sold Nickelback's that like
they didn't know about financing yeah it
was a whole different it was different
you know gang prostitution problems and
when I watched the Sons of Anarchy
and they showed Kurt cesari's and all
the cholos and when Jimmy Smits came it
if you live and where Jeff Garcia is
from where's he from
I point them up went they look went
there has like seven gangs in La Puente
and each a gang is assigned to a
different turf uh-huh and have that turf
they shade down and they financed by
selling street drugs and that's that
that's their yes
they make pennies to a dollar yeah but
in their world they're [ __ ] big shots
and that's the socio-economic that's
what it is that's what it's created for
so I get all that the when I was a kid
in the Bronx I didn't understand and
went out like I said when I when I would
go to Harlem I heard about the ghetto
boys because kids would brag about all
the things yeah and the word on the
street about the ghetto boys is that
they had a [ __ ] bazooka they
was showing up so and the song was do
you wanna get it higher with again oh
brother
power oh yeah our power like that was
like that little theme [ __ ] of how
five well I didn't know nobody and no
gangs I didn't run no nobody came up to
me and asked me if I wanted to cut my
hand and shake hands yeah you didn't say
nothing like that I can't yeah now a man
like speaking of juvenile hall like a
lot of my friends went to juvenile hall
and and in California there's juvenile
hall and then there's those crazy
[ __ ] to go to cya California
Youth Authority
I had a homemade I was in there from
like 13 or 14 to 25 they call it adult
life like instead of sending you to
prison you go from 14 to 25 and like he
was [ __ ] he got out and he was just
like Dawg it ain't like prison over here
there there is gangbanging Mexicans and
Mexicans is like look you're from my
opposite gang we're gonna go back we're
gonna fight it was like some crazy [ __ ]
home but with telling like [ __ ]
would like get your ass beat like in
there if you drop something and picked
it up they put you on this thing called
the level where like from now on people
can just sock you and do whatever they
want if you drop something it's just
gone that's it Dawg like if you're
drinking coffee and that's it falls
you're like hey my boy like yeah Dawg
and those guys they go to prison and
they're out of [ __ ] control they call
them why a babies those [ __ ] a
why a baby like he don't [ __ ] around and
yeah man that's a that's that's what
they ate a shut two of them down Joey so
many [ __ ] were getting like bad
[ __ ] happening to him they had one in
Norwalk or one in Sacramento and [ __ ] I
can't imagine hey dawg I heard people
get raped in there oh please that's
that's the main because it's the main
[ __ ] thing Tom they're kids what do
you think they're doing they're savages
they don't know yeah they don't have the
manpower at those places to control
those people and they're doing like six
seven years you know at that age you
don't get a head doesn't comprehend it
like your head doesn't comprehend them
like you can see the let's talk about
the Miami this shooter in Florida like I
just saw a picture him there's a shooter
in Florida got that just went off at the
school okay let go yeah that kid you
know he
he doesn't even know what is going on
like he doesn't know what's going on and
now they're gonna put him into a system
that doesn't really know what that
they're going on in any any special
treatment so he's gonna be in the
psychiatric services to rest or they're
gonna mad a mop too and they're gonna
med you up you know the prison the
prison system is not a good [ __ ] now
it's not a good [ __ ] system
especially now you can't smoke in there
can you right now you can see it's all
money now it costs three bucks a [ __ ]
cigarette for a Pinner if you had like a
real marble light you can break that up
into five cigarettes it's all bad
it's all [ __ ] bad and you know what's
even crazier about the prisons I just
read about is now that they have a
regular a prison has two yards they got
a protective custody or special need
yards for gays snitches people that
essentially call pedophiles they
separate them from the main main line
fools like me that like a dog now
there's so many of these [ __ ] on this
side they're the the living is they
can't live there what does it call bad
living or something by living through
this yeah bad living condition so now
they're putting all these [ __ ]
on the main line and telling the main
line like hey you're gonna stab this
forward it's gonna give you life so
they're creating riots every [ __ ] day
and I guess an inmate wrote a letter to
like their family and now there's
families outside protesting saying dude
my my husband has six months left he's
been down for 15 years and you're gonna
put a pedophile on his yard knowing that
they have to stab his [ __ ] like
that's some talking crazy [ __ ] once they
find out that because I didn't go to any
of the big presence I went through the
system first you go to that place where
they test you yeah be ready Saturday and
your questions and that was [ __ ]
three weeks of hell
I was three we suggest no sleep people
yelling all night it was cold and the
bed was metal had they transfer me to
another place for about a more two weeks
that was okay they had pods there was
fistfights too was shanking huh well I I
read books that's it I didn't know
nobody I made friends as a black dude
and that was it then I went to my
destination my destination was a prison
camp yeah there was a barrack for
snitches yeah but you weren't supposed
to know they would not witness we
located guys there were that other thing
that they put in there well that Peschel
needs special protection yeah you don't
even know we didn't PC protective
custody right you didn't know and then
somebody would get a letter from
somebody going hey yeah it's this guy
your camp this guy was the one that
ratted out gonzales brothers in 1984
he's just getting out stabbed him like
it would go like that and we adhered it
but the prison camp I was at was very
calm it was one of the best camps they
had enough in veins for the thing the
City of Gold didn't really monitor it is
when they make Coors beer [ __ ] don't
work didn't want it there some boys
fought against it making it grow and all
this [ __ ] they wouldn't hire the people
from the plant where the other prison
camp of that nature rifle the City of
rifle close to Aspen about of the howl
of the mass but they the community gave
you jobs so even though you were in
prison in the summer you worked at the
pool as a lifeguard or selling popcorn
when the hot dog in the winter you
worked at the ski resort okay they would
let you work at the ski resort Wow and
there was people who worked at the movie
theater
Wow like on the trash out on the right
we were allowed to leave for 20 minutes
a day you know damn we gotta get none of
that [ __ ] yeah I was a lot this is
before furloughs yeah and we're crazy in
Boston then when I got into prison they
were still furloughs oh [ __ ] you did
like ten years and you had five left you
were eligible for furloughs if you but
your behavior had to be impeccable
impeccable
like impact of
which was really hard it's too hard
Becca boy it's got to be impeccable like
if there's a sock outside your locker
like that in haiku okay but what uh the
camp it you heard the one thing with me
was that when I went there was still the
isolation groups but because I knew
about money and how money worked I went
through there with no drum and a horse -
the kitchen is filled with blacks and
Mexicans so I had them from the kitchen
and then then you have the white power
group and you had the bikers that's
weird that they separated like that all
that he had at that time it was the
white power group and then bikers and
then there was this one white power dude
that was a different life power dude Wow
hated a certain type of people
but he was really badass so when I went
to prison he became my friend he was
from Philly okay so I [ __ ] with those
white dudes uh-huh the biker white dude
was an involuntary manslaughter and he
wasn't a good dude yeah he could just
tell but he Gamble's with me so he was
cool the white dude the one who hated
blacks and Latinos and Jews he was a
Jared gambler and he loved Mexican food
he loved [ __ ] burritos
hi I'm Mexican her dude in him that
would do business all the time that's
why that joke from Jerry Rocha has
always made me laugh about and go home
for Christmas and white people being in
this house for Christmas in the back
that hate Mexican people but then they
like Miami this house is good
look at them they're [ __ ] up the
words the jingle bells and all this [ __ ]
you know I love that joke when he says
look at them [ __ ] up the words -
jingle bells this bean dip is sure gonna
tasty that that I mean the guy that
hated Mexicans love Mexican food so on
Sundays he kind of deal with the Mexican
dude the dude give him green chili
burritos haha and they still go bananas
I didn't really experience that like you
see in the movies where we're at war but
not really I can't talk to George
because I'm with the entire dog I lived
that [ __ ] George can't talk to me to
have the Mexicans and then we'll get
thrown into a laundry and after a week
he you gotta say something to me I can
you believe that [ __ ] yeah say something
I can you would know already because if
we did talk like look Joey if you're my
enemy in there we know each other from
yeah but we're not enemies let's say I'm
with the Italians I'm with the Cubans I
mean you're allowed to then but if
you're the Cubans have no dealings with
si is not the fact we're friends we see
yeah oh yeah we can't believe this where
I was at there was no contact with any
black at all there was it was it was
just common like excuse me
good morning that's it it wasn't more
like a dog so where are you from
how would your birthday what's your
favorite color the Jews hang out with
because we can't hang out with the Aryan
Brotherhood you guys get great lawyers
bro they're not that they're not too
many Jews in there that's funny but
there is and you guys roll with the
others there's others yeah others is
theirs Mexican white black and others
and by saw there's paisa to it and there
others is like you hang out with like
the Asian Samoans Russians Italians
Samoans okay yeah now whatever torn up
Isis elected a jail a paisa is someone
that is not from America they're Mexico
El Salvador and during when you're
Mexican your just from here or you claim
it you're from a gang if you're not from
a gang you're Mets getting your to say
dog I'm a by SIA all right cool you know
you're Mexican and you're done the game
you've been robbing on your own 20 years
and you go to prison you have to join
one thing you gotta choose homie or
[ __ ] how many gangs are out to choose
for the Mexican that's it like northern
in southern I don't I don't speak on
that but okay what about like Kings
hail naw they would be like look homie
you're over here this is our rules
that's it were there Latin Kings were
you were at nah they don't yes
oh yeah that's East Coast that's that's
a horn of the flavor because Latin Kings
they got white black met they have every
race in there really hell yeah I got the
Latin Kings of the Spanish dude the
Dominicans and you know some Dominican
[ __ ] this black person thinking they
were Dominican and it's so mixed up how
scared should I be outside my building
there's an ms-13 tag on I'm like the
wall that's probably like the [ __ ]
guy that delivers parking it was like my
[ __ ] plaque on the wall right fair
enough
I know but is it old new like it looks
it's the first time I've seen it
recently yeah where do you I don't don't
tell me it's and I live in like near
Studio City it's not about area
thirteen-year-old kids you [ __ ] block
that [ __ ] do you think so I know so look
at the [ __ ] neighborhood yeah it's
Studio City done what are you doing over
there yeah what are they doing well you
know there's a [ __ ] pizza place over
there going to Danielle yeah it's okay
nice people my son is they've gotten
broken into three times people are
hungry now it's right yeah then I drove
by there a little Canyon I was parked at
the light and i sat there at the light
and I lured the window it's not used to
be a burger court if you smashed that
window the whole neighborhood here is it
he said that all three times the camera
didn't catch it no call it you know you
got me qual he wakes up he calls the
cops he's watching him on the camera on
his phone as they're going in going for
the he goes I leave $40 in here at night
but the point of the story is that I was
sitting there as a gas station that's
open 24 hours there's a jack of the Box
that's open 24 hours there's a Subway
sandwich on the corner that's in there
hidden next to a Starbucks
nobody heard like he's like it's the
weirdest thing i sat there in the car I
know as a burglar
if I would break that the way it it
would echo it would just echo this
language store there I mean it's tough
to be a burglar now [ __ ] these cameras
there is cameras everywhere in people's
houses and you ever catch them on the
news
they get confused they take the camera
off the scratch their head the camera
get some right now it's [ __ ] hard he
wouldn't be so [ __ ] hard to do
anything anymore like I think that [ __ ]
I used to do and I would have been
busted trusted I would I would like
steal her cell phone and subscribers
were spread stories on it alright and
subscriber
[ __ ] this [ __ ] about cell phones but I
would just be [ __ ] robbed and [ __ ] I
used to rob houses but never like I was
[ __ ] Joey I wanted [ __ ] dawg so when I
was like 18
I wouldn't rob a house but I got four
rich ass no disrespect but rich has
we're inviting me to her crib I was
going down come on yeah I hate this from
the age of 16 to 30 everything I did was
a case with the house you just put
yourself on a list for me to rob look
around yeah look have you invited with
the house I got that's what I would do
hey I have a security expert when I look
at your house I could tell you if you're
gonna get wrong and why healing it
robbed by a rock yeah different
percentages you know if you leave your
backpack in the front seat of your car
your computer they're gonna break it if
you put on the front floor you're black
the backpack is black and they don't see
it they're not gonna bring you out the
cover of it that's what it's only
[ __ ] stupid what life is about you
know in the one thing I never did was I
hated car stereos but there was just so
many things that I wouldn't do
there was a point for years in America
you robbed the car stereo you couldn't
do nothing with because once you took it
out he couldn't play in another car
mm-hmm unless it was aftermarket like if
you went ball like that whatever but if
you took like a crisis stereo there's
nothing you could do with it even if you
put in another crisis I was [ __ ]
there's so many crimes that people do
for a little [ __ ] and they cause so much
havoc yeah and it pisses me off like a
few leaves dollar bills and a certain
little of your thing you know you pay
for tolls you have to put change in
there they're gonna break them you put
singles in there they're gonna break
your window
they're gonna break your window for the
morning for [ __ ] done yeah and now
you got to pay a hundred yeah and now
you just paid 150 this when I'm going to
a place I look at the security of the
place and I look at the people and I
asked if I go to the bathroom I love the
people that you go to the bathroom it
you have to walk through a bedroom they
got a jewelry box right yeah you're
going down you're doing nothing I'm
gonna get the case of the [ __ ] to steal
one of your wedding I mean it was just
dumb like when people have parties how
it robbed parties all the time like if
people would say hello yeah it's a
party's a friend of mine he's having a
party in Tenafly that's the first place
as you want and next you know you're on
the second floor under the bed with the
little girl's [ __ ] pony Bank in the
frankish [ __ ] it's [ __ ] embarrassing
dog it's embarrassing [ __ ] there's some
crazy [ __ ] I've done some space to break
into his house so much that they would
leave me notes
[ __ ] you wipe your feet [ __ ] like I
would rob him once every 90 days for
like two years
oh [ __ ] I robbed him once every 90 days
a drug deal everything they could I
would just robbed just a lot of no that
was stupid
yeah just to let him know the stupid
they had a back window that I could open
like nothing and nothing pisses me off
more than when I robbed you and I come
back and you start that yeah I will rob
you again just out of principle I robbed
that [ __ ] apartment it was a [ __ ]
gay dude who sold drugs and I knew he
had to work like I knew him to another
gay guy and I knew he had I would rob
him certain I was tan like the first few
places I robbed
to him but the first time he left money
in like a jar in his uh like on a
dresser down a dresser oh I just sucked
my hand and then it was $450 ah that's
my line ride a morning oh there was I
gonna help to cope somewhere Oh oh my
god and then that way like 90 days he
never accused me and I went back again
this time he hid in his love his room
and I robbed that one and then I went
back like six months later and I grabbed
him again for something else for coke
again and then after that I waited and I
robbed him again and I went to the first
two spots and both of them had notes
like [ __ ] you [ __ ] years later like
why don't you leave him a note back like
haha that type of timely yeah let's say
he's a stenographer oh [ __ ] dumb he
doesn't that bi dude I used to do some
creepy [ __ ] don't there was a dude that
just pissed me you know I think I told
this story this is war and I went to
Colorado
you know those [ __ ] every time
you're cooking you're about to eat they
ring your doorbell and they're like man
how is his name was Kent uh-huh he was
from in Turkey telemarketer no he was
just a white dude that wasn't he lived
upstairs oh he wanted to talk and he
right above me but he always knew we
were cooking you know he's not gonna do
anything I hope I didn't interrupt
nothing Shawn I got with me being
[ __ ] me and go you wanna sit and get
some Daisy sure you know who's those
goofy dudes that wrote a bike with a
helmet on I'm gonna be a tease is [ __ ]
huh
so you know weed smoke power living [ __ ]
and he was like an artist type dude at
the time he's way old if I was 18 he had
to be like 25 but he lived right above
me I lived on the first floor and he
lived right above me on the second floor
you know we became friends like friends
for like four months he would come over
at night and smoke well that's a lot of
people did any Rob you guys know you
pissed me off
Oh his mother sent him money and he came
to brag the by Michael you know I just
made like the time I said what's the
story want you to go to six bracket yeah
come over been drinking with us you know
you here every night smoking up on eat
our food
he's a con oh man I gotta hold on to
this money is this kind of lastly and
that night he went out to a bar and
Aspen like I'm the way out he came I was
watching TV and I had money at the time
not millionaire money yeah but I had it
I was making like 10 bucks an hour the
rent was paid they had like a dungeon in
the back a little more watching TV just
being pissed off that this [ __ ]
wouldn't even buy a six-pack yeah then
the door knocks that's him all dressed
up he's like I'm going to aspect anybody
want to come
I had to meet some girls up there and
all this [ __ ] I'm gonna have a good time
I'm like this guy there's a normal to
rob this [ __ ] because I know
he's cheap he didn't take all the money
with him yeah positive because he got it
later in the day so there's got to be
cash upstairs so I waited like an hour
downstairs my roommate was on a date I
was all by myself lonely [ __ ] I had the
money to get coke but I was around this
[ __ ] boy and I went out there I
put a table out there and I tried to
jump I couldn't make it so I put a chair
on top of a table and I went out there
like a Houdini I still couldn't match
and I put like a chair on top of the
chair and top my chair and thought the
table finally [ __ ] got this balcony
and bro the balcony was open I just had
a slider Dolson and I went in the house
and I looked everywhere I [ __ ] looked
everywhere for that money and I could
not find it
he had a bicycle little pouch in the bag
where you pull I give the [ __ ] before
ya respect I I wanted there not that
this [ __ ] took her with him I
went back the house but I left the front
door open because sometimes I leave the
front door open just to think about I
come back and [ __ ] about an hour late I
went to the bathroom I hit the bathroom
and sure enough I open up a metal band
aid case and there's his Jesus ha ha ha
ho bills I take the money I closed and I
closed the mirror I locked the balcony
but I leave the front door open so when
he comes home he knows this front doors
open
yeah I think I liked it so next more
than sure enough first thing he's like
hey man I got robbed last night
oh really what time I just played it off
then he left he came back and saying you
know what man I've been thinking you and
your roommate you both to to night to
New York City hustlers what a piece is
shared every day you have burglarized
the place once or twice in your life
before I think you burglarize Merced
can't hide in burglars you came back
downstairs with a piece of scotch tape
he said I got fingerprints I'm gonna
take him down there's no mass police
department right now
and get the fingerprint lifted from this
guy's table I'm like all this poor
bastard
and they never talk to me again he knew
I robbed atop my room and I know was him
I know yeah [ __ ] yeah I'm gonna Rob you
had just buy a six-pack of beer I was no
it's a lesson learned dog yeah whoo [ __ ]
like that [ __ ] with me
share the [ __ ] we buy by eating steaks I
used to go every night and shoplift two
steaks no I would buy salami
I would buy an Oscar Mayer salami a big
kinda head of lettuce and I would take
two t-bone steaks and put them in my
winter jacket and go home on the shuttle
and I'd have my roommate cook the steaks
and I cut the salami and cut lettuce and
put salami tomatoes and lettuce and make
like a generous salad with vinegar oil
and we just make [ __ ] t-bone steaks
that [ __ ] sounds bomb dog I don't
[ __ ] around since the early age I don't
[ __ ] around
yeah I feel I'd steal those my steep
like those ten-dollar t-bone back in the
day at $10 t-bone that was big time yeah
[ __ ] I was a one-man [ __ ] Wrecking
Crew oh yeah and I loved it a lot I
think about it sometimes I'm like
thought I feel bad for the sins I did
but no I didn't because most of the
people I robbed would just play now
scumbags yeah I think I I got robbed
when I was like 21 by my baby's mom and
I didn't like put it together till I was
like 33 how'd you get robbed
oh I I broke up with her and back then I
used to my parents like they owned
houses so they were like look you guys
could stay in this house it's a
four-bedroom I ran out one bedroom and
then just pay the difference all right
cool
so my baby's mom back then was a big-ass
[ __ ] Tweaker and she used to hang out
she's been to juvenile hall
my baby's mom the oldest one though
she's 40 might know she's from my son
Georgia my daughter's 11 my other sons
19 in my Georgie's 22 Georgie his mom
she [ __ ] so I told her hey you got
till today to take all your [ __ ] out and
I didn't come home because I was out
[ __ ] other bit [ __ ]
and I come home and the whole house has
ketchup and shaving cream all over the
carpet like back then I [ __ ] DVD
player was I 150 they took all my [ __ ]
and they even robbed the roommate that
was there and she was hanging out with
the girl that was dating some food I had
a I had a jewelry like a pawnshop
jewelry and [ __ ] and they took all the
jewelry and I just put it all together
later cuz I seen that fool for the
jewelry shop he was like yo Dawg did you
lady ever give you all that money from
the come up I was like what come up he
wasn't ya dog she told me that you guys
you guys robbed somebody she but you
didn't want to come in so you brought
the jewels in she brought him in so it
wouldn't look like you did it nothing
it's robbed me dawg she would have been
my first my first suspect he just broke
up with her she like they would catch up
and I am I know but it was more like I
was kind of scared of her dog I just
wanted her out of the [ __ ] house you
know what I mean cause like she had
cousins that would come down and [ __ ]
stab me I was just more like hey I'll
take this $300 loss get the [ __ ] out of
here I'd say what there's nothing I get
robbed because you're a thief you just
write it off with no drama exactly the
first time I got beat I got beat big dog
I was about 16 I was about 17 and I was
working at Putnam field pumping gas Oh
where's that button fuel Putnam fuel
this place it was it was on the border
of North Bergen one from Secaucus New
Jersey okay Dan G a gastrulation dog
drivers den jeeps women sucking dick in
the back you know just slapping him in
the back degree Jesus is know people do
all with doing black beauties snort
black beauties oh look the capsule and
snort the black beauties and [ __ ] ass
sniffing paint on that [ __ ] I don't know
what they did back there I never got
involved
I knew they were white and they were
scary and they look like people from
walking dead in the warning that wasn't
even out yet so I left him alone but I
got a job working there
and you know
it was a couple nights a week the gammy
elves got me the job
Holyoke Gambian whose brother Caesar
were both big time is that they had
worked there all their life his kids
like since never ate and now they would
hire people for partner it was open 24
hours and folks 190s brothers came in
cool and [ __ ] black dudes mm-hmm look
like all four super flies to garlic our
pay for the gas tip me and I can you get
rid of some reefer you like smoking
reefer I'm like [ __ ] yet they gonna come
back look at the trunk of the car I
think I opened up the trunk of the car
it was like [ __ ] ten pounds of
marijuana ha they said take a bud bro I
took a bud and I cut that bud and I
rolled it up and I saw the [ __ ] devil
I saw the devil they had a friend that
had big money
he sold coke this is 1980 I'm in high
school my mother just died and this dude
was a [ __ ] pedophile the dude was
like just are we one stain and a
pedophile put together he's on Facebook
now I'm gonna call him out his [ __ ] but
like I was a kid I would go to his house
and he always had a robot there was a
couple people in those days always
iRobot there was a pedophile on my block
all Puerto Rican Nelson you always had a
robot this [ __ ] would help you
play football with a robot I want you to
suck this dick of no underwear yeah with
a robot I'm playing football this [ __ ]
helping you change the tire with a robot
in the [ __ ] wintertime is [ __ ] and
this dude this dude I had a friend that
couldn't wasn't allowed to go to dudes
house for a certain reason oh so he
would give me money and I would go to
dudes house and let made me look like a
big shot dude and him were cousins but
do was a cop no she couldn't be seen
with dude yeah so dude would go go over
there by a gram 2 grams 3 grand and it
would help my credit I go and said look
i'm song for you throw me a little
something yeah straight up like a gin
I'm 17 I don't know how many times I
don't know whether this guy would always
have a [ __ ] robe on
[ __ ] what time of the day were you going
over there always right after school I
would get out of school was it just
underwear under like he would have like
bikini on the way and I mean every time
I wanted there he'd be coked out from
the night before this before anybody was
getting coked up like whoa the only
people I saw getting coke them from them
before at that time was my mother and
her friends this is the sense outside of
the house now this is my mother was dead
and this is the first guy that would get
high and I would call him like a 2 and
Sam coming over and he was still harping
like before like the dude in Boogie
Nights
I know exactly that was like that dude
what his hair still going with the
Chinese guy firecrackers yeah he always
had like a guy over there or some creepy
girl there's always something going on
when you went to his house but I would
go over there all the time and buy coke
from him and front coke from him and he
always took care of me so I just I took
him to weed and I go listen man I bumped
into these [ __ ] jobs from heaven they
got a hotel room up in room four for
eight up here and they gave me their
number they got the bag or smoked it
tell me what you think the guy called me
the next days I talked that's the best
weed out of the smoke in my life I think
they wanted ain't on YouTube but I don't
know I think they want a 600 pound i
tacked on to zactly huh they wanted
three packs paddy boy that was his name
so I'll take three pounds so I went over
there a certain time I people up to
three pounds I picked up the cash and I
met the black dudes at the [ __ ] in
Putnam feel until this day I don't know
how they did it
I'd happen it was one of those give us
the cash go to the trunk and pull the
weed out and when I went to the trunk
I pulled the weed out and they said
don't we got cops watching us but don't
look at it she get to your car ah I got
in the back seat I opened it and it was
loud so let's say three pounds is 32 and
16 is 42 48 ounces there was maybe four
ounces of real weed on
ha yeah the rest was just a brick
condensed and I didn't know I took it to
him like a [ __ ] drive to go till Mike
told he took it to none other remember
when Tony Montana took the guy the key
little kokum yeah friend angel for that
this died yeah but this is my gift to
you yeah how old would have liked
thinking how is Johnny Bruce Bochy like
here's what I did the guy took the top
bag out the rest were bricks Hey look me
in the face of yours listen I don't know
if you know how men do this we got beat
and in reality I didn't get beat you got
beat so I gave you 1800 cash I need my
money back whatever he's like that gave
me 2400 cash I need my money back I
needed back in two days that's the first
time I ever got put like that was like
yeah it's mission time I couldn't get
him beat up I couldn't be the mouse in
my world that's what it is if I call Lee
and I go leak George Perez is giving you
a gig down in Oklahoma you go down and
George don't pay it you gotta look at me
next time shut your [ __ ] mouth
yeah how you learn to shut your [ __ ]
mouth you don't know nothing about
nothing cuz George beat them and then it
happens it's gonna happen it happens in
concentrate you gonna you go somewhere
you got a basketball for a check uh-huh
you don't know do you come I did I did
Pechanga supposed to get 2400 that guy I
was that was supposed to pay me start
this [ __ ] brought his luggage in
my room hung up his clothes in the
closet and [ __ ] we got drunk did coke I
[ __ ] passed out I woke up everything
was gone but his clothes never paid me
nothing
finally I [ __ ] found that floor I
don't I don't want to say his name but
you know who he is he's a punk
[ __ ]
I just went out in like a straight
manner I said look Dawg I need 200 bucks
every two months I don't care what your
problems are I lost out big I'm supposed
to make like $2,500 left with like minus
500 cuz you know you gamble at Pechanga
Yui you stay and all that my [ __ ] got
me good no but that was the first time I
got beat and they did it beautifully and
I got beat that is smooth I got beat in
the city when you buy acid
on 42nd Street in the old days they
would tell you the same line okay don't
look at it t get down the corner and
then you open it up there's a coffee
filter it's a [ __ ] piece of paper
with coffee stain on it how you blood
acid you know those feelings are
horrible boss ain't no worse beaten I
have a tough dog I was selling cars
George huh George
yes your name I don't know what I'm
sorry cause I'm the type of [ __ ]
when I'm wheeling and dealing
it's across the dorm business but when
my sweats involved straight up it's it's
a different story
well I'm wheeling dealing I'll give you
whatever you want
well I'm sweating stepping on toes and
you're stepping on toes so tell about
how you were dealing cars
I was selling cars and I'd put away
money you were put away money uh yeah
like a dog I was not even in the bank
I'd never put away money at this time I
got out of prison and I said you know
what I'm gonna start taking care of
myself a little but and I got a job
washing cars it hurts and they put me in
the employee residential management
program so they gave me an extra two
hours I was making okay money my rent
was 450 a month I was two in the corner
you know and I put away this money I
don't want to tell the amount it doesn't
matter I put it away for two months I've
tried out of the prison you like when
you get out of jail I was out on bail as
a matter of fact I'm on bail I'm just
about put the pieces together and I got
a [ __ ] VCR and a brand-new Sony
whatever the [ __ ] it was brand-new bro I
had never paid for nothing I had always
got I would put TVs I'm stolen credit
card by installing I would steal the GA
myself this is the first time I sweat
and you know when that came on my [ __ ]
was gone my roommate George was his name
at the time of the joint did you leave
the doorknob
they robbed my [ __ ] I'll never fit like
that I'm a thief I was a thief
but I've also been robbed so I know what
the perspective is I know pays Paul
Peter pays ball like you you just it's
it it's like when you get a like when I
got arrested for the kidnapping I
accepted it like I accepted it I
accepted it for all my other sins mm-hmm
I didn't kidnap nobody you told what are
you talking about kidnapping I didn't
send nobody a ransom note no kidnapping
is when you do this and this and this
Perez and it's like last week I made a
joke but I'll say this again with a
different context you see what Ronda
Rousey got kicked in the head yeah what
she was laying there sitting there do
you think she was thinking about the 8
million she was nothing yet no she was
taking them out on the station 8:00
tonight at that place when they're
putting the handcuffs on you
uh-huh that's what you're thinking about
Harry that Baylor says that judge says
bailiff put the cops in and take them
into the back when they put those ankles
on you for a minute you think about all
the things you did you think about
throwing a rock at that priest when you
were 6 Robbie not only these patties you
think about the bicycle tube you stole
it all comes back to you and you know
they say what's in your grandma's water
yeah they say that when you die your
life flashes before you it happens in a
lot of situations in your life you know
like when you're bombing at the Comedy
Store Mitzi's in the back and you're
eating a bag of dicks and you're seeing
your wife in front of you and you're
also playing your suicide while you're
on stage you can't even focus on
material because you don't know whether
you're gonna jump off the Santa Monica
bridge or you gonna jump off of some
over the [ __ ] whatever you don't know
I mean that's that that's the truth you
know what it's like to bomb and find
Mitzy
I don't know Wednesday night all it's
quiet yeah Wyatt [ __ ] you could hear
hell I never got the performer from
there you can you can hear toenails
growing is this in the Oh our room or on
the original ok she saw me the bag of
dicks to the mail room one time but
there was one particular time in the
original like it's in there where the
Harmon wouldn't be a Sadie nothing does
she tell you [ __ ] when you eat dicks or
is it like she would make an offhand
compliment or say something to you
with you but at the same time you would
take it she would never go find you know
how cameras shoot that was yeah her
world she would just say it wasn't your
night
I don't wait that junk hey she said she
thought Rogan one time he couldn't do
the end the cold joke because people
couldn't follow it that's a cop dance I
can't be doing that joke around hit
those [ __ ] fall apart yeah
Rogan was Howard she's all run around
you can do that room I jump in the main
room dog I had a call that old dude she
married he wanted a Kentucky Fried
hooker and all that sure you can't cuz
that building that bit used to chisel
level room yeah before he died he was 90
and his dying wish mr. guy a Kentucky
Fried hook here so he married on the
call his family was pleading with him
don't do it she wants your money I don't
give a [ __ ] it was a great bit I forgot
it word for word but I yeah and bro when
he would do it the comic in front of him
they got comical had a follow you would
just see their shoulders go down go down
cuz they know there's gonna be a long
night
this is when he was still yelling how
came he was younger he was yelling he
was Kennison in a little bit okay he
ripped he was ripping me apart bro I was
just gonna tear it apart
oh yeah but if that had like cold bed
then they you know that's how a joke and
the joke ended with him dying like
please don't die and he's like I'm my
dad my boss holy [ __ ] and that would
just blow up the [ __ ] room but she
would tell you little things okay and
she was right you see a good gift she's
seen it on your spending up you sped up
your set tonight you'd walk faster I can
disgust but you'd walk past I like
knowing I'm not gonna go how we going
[ __ ] another spot here we go
when you got off that stage you like
that's it
that was my run at the Comedy Store also
you call the next weekend you got five
spots oh wow because she understood well
yeah that when the baby was sat in I ate
a bag of dicks bro oh yeah I'm on our
show they just weren't buying me okay
but in the fifth minute I didn't do what
I used to do an inexperienced comic
folds in the main room at the five
minute mark and it's a long time that
white comes on up there talking and now
you starting to turn red now you're
starting to do strolling jokes you think
about Cosby [ __ ] he's in jail that
Terios fries [ __ ] now yeah you just want
that [ __ ] like that
I just kept plowing through it I knew
they didn't like me I knew they didn't
like the joke I opened up with I opened
up with a joke that was a little too
strong at the seven o'clock show and now
you gotta pay for your sentence I've
been there before but I can't give up
I'd go back standing on my two feet and
plow through it like they gonna get it
like I'm home for [ __ ] when I got out
I could beast out when I was walking up
they were like look at me like ill they
would give me the ill thing and I went
into that [ __ ] original and I just
waited a beat on him bro it was
basically I went out I touch gloves man
threw a jab to feel whether it's my
distance was uh-huh I just started
taking body shots like Rocky in the 8th
ramp I was just hitting body shots don't
ma'am even Kate quickly called me she
was like what the [ __ ] and just did 45
minutes of 15 that's where I do ba you
do 40 15 minutes of punchlines a 10
seconds a 10 second set up and just
punch lines of 15 minutes that's when
you just having fun you just dissect
your act okay I got a couple
chitter-chatter and just lay it on you
got 45 minutes you got 15 so you're just
laying around what are you giving them
is just body shots at the end of the set
they just scattered like a massacre
they're like all over the place trying
to hold on themselves I love all that
[ __ ] I love all that [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah I'm
excited to be working with you man all
the knowledge I'm gonna get and know
what knowledge I get knowledge from you
nah nah it's just like though you always
teach me like how to act and should I
remember once how you believe hey you
can't be going into the improv with your
nose looking like that I was like oh
[ __ ] like I remember like you know
always tell me a dog don't party til
you're done you know what I mean because
I used to [ __ ] party hard dog I'd be
drunken [ __ ] I don't know if you
remember but you'd always tell me that
[ __ ]
I didn't there was a certain etiquette
listen when you go to a club now when
you start headlining you're gonna figure
something much you're gonna walk into a
club and they can't wait to tell you
gossip okay they can't wait to say about
who got ten hook this last week yeah I
can't wait to tell you about Pablo
staying till Wednesday and they can't
wait to tell you about this guy you know
doing [ __ ] to the waitstaff where they
had fire and wait people they can't wait
because I'm normal when I go to those
clubs I'm very thankful to be there you
know there's people that lose that light
and they lose their mind they leave them
away and they lose their mind therefore
do you mean by that they go to they go
to Nashville in their minds they're
[ __ ] real stars
I got anyway I got you you know I never
bought into that [ __ ] I gotta stay very
on my credit so I I seen people a
thousand credits suck the biggest dicks
on stage
give me the guy with no credits that
[ __ ] they'll kill you
you go to a local town as a feature
he'll kill you you own all feature [ __ ]
doing [ __ ] about the city and he knows
what's going on with there they'll kill
you those local features sometimes
they'll bury they know about everything
you know the political or the city the
views of the city and they're good they
had laughs they just have they just
featuring for you ain't got no credit
you better [ __ ] watch yourself dog
they'll [ __ ] bury you those guys
those guys that know about the area and
the landmarks and they grew up there and
[ __ ] they're dead [ __ ] local comics
you know when I lived in Seattle you
know it's funny when I lived in Seattle
when I left Seattle I had 30 minutes
when I got that lay at 18
why because it was about Seattle oh okay
when you live in a place you become a
local at that place that's your bed
you know what do you what I'm gonna do
here talk about traffic done
talk about the pollution done yeah we're
gonna talk about this too many Mexicans
done
there's too many Armenians done they've
all been done you know open up that door
for me a little bit you know so that's
the problem you have but once when
you're developing in Boston like if you
go to Boston I've never been to Boston
you go to an open mic on Monday in
Boston they're talking to my local [ __ ]
and you're dying you're [ __ ] dying
it's just yeah I mean I'm down for all
that [ __ ] I can't wait till I get out to
Boston all that [ __ ] morning I want to
die with them and come back right that's
all right now you're at that precipice
you're at that precipice with your
featuring your headline and you're I'm
seeing you got the credits you've been
on Showtime I mean you're right there
you're not gonna have its door you get
developmental spots at the store I don't
know if you've looked around earlier
they ain't too many Mexicans at the
store no nice ooze Trejo yeah that's it
you know in the old days it was 18
Mexicans at the [ __ ] County still no
way yeah yeah yeah
damn Freddie Johnny Luke Luke where is
Luke I don't know I see he posted
something kind of funny like he said
that he had a bad dream and that he said
he had a bad dream and he was watching a
movie with the gay Rambo and he called
him rambro and he's like they these are
they suck [ __ ] first now I mean you know
they drew blood first you know Luke dog
he's in a band he's a comedian right cuz
he was it he always loved music yeah
he's good he was a music guy he was
always a music I think he's I think he
does two or three years again a year as
a cop yeah I'm [ __ ] I don't know I might
hear grinding trying to get mine
hustling working on Sean together how
long have you been doing comedy there 16
17 years but you got to take three off
cuz I did three years in prisons which
is time yeah you did time served in
there that'll be funny yeah selim once
you told people your chameleon will tell
me something funny bro ha ha that's the
worst
that's the I was hiding being a commune
I don't want no one to know the [ __ ]
guards are the ones that [ __ ] burned
me all the other ones yeah cuz the
guards are at the prison I was that the
last one I was that was in Norco and
Riverside
so these [ __ ] guards they've been too
while coyotes a patio Ontario improv
they been to the Ice House these [ __ ]
knew me like nothing but they were like
homie I used to watch you a customer
Tina it was [ __ ] crazy
that's crazy [ __ ] like when a cop would
be like what's up George on my pit you
can't say [ __ ] hi to me and make me
look like a snitch or something yeah so
they never made you go on stage right I
went on stage in prison a lot and all
the dorms they had dorms and a lot of
the guards or they're mostly Mexican or
like black but like yeah they were they
were there in there 12 hours 15 hours
themselves they were like [ __ ] yeah go
up there do comedy so they would set it
up and I would do comedy in each dorm
yeah I was dope dog I had an opener I
found some Puerto Rican for that was my
opener his name was Rico he was from
Norwalk but that [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
ended up rolling it up rolling it up
means when you tell to go to the
protective custody yard because you know
they're gonna get you yeah you know
drugs [ __ ] get everybody that forgot
[ __ ] you were doing stand-up in how
many minutes would you do I'll do 25 32
all he nights a week once a month cuz
like they had to make passes for me
because when you're in prison there's
movement so I had to go through two
stations to get to where I was going
like the guards will call it in you know
I'm sending Perez with two people they
got a radio I would bring a radio like I
would play music before the show and
[ __ ] and then I would get my opener to
go up and do four minutes
best intro I ever [ __ ] had Joey this
for girls you might have seen him on
Comedy Central now you could see him on
the yard he's I give it up for Joey
Perez in there like it was a dog it was
fun as [ __ ] and it made me realize
that a lot of criminals are naturally
funny because like usually when you get
off stage and you do a show and no one's
gonna try to give you a tag or like a
little something for your joke the
[ __ ] gangster cholo said they were
giving me [ __ ] funny as tangs hey
well you should say there's a I was like
oh [ __ ] I'm gonna use that yeah it was
it was cool it was fun
hey Dawg it was fun but I just remember
like [ __ ] Joey be a Friday night 7:30
and I probably think the reason I
started doing cocaine again is I got
this anxiety of like I'm locked up I
can't go out and like be a man tell
jokes go [ __ ] go to the liquor store
go [ __ ] to the movies you know what I
mean I'm in there and my window there's
a park across the street or this family
is having fun people playing and that
anxiety was [ __ ] killing me I
remember I called Felipe Esparza one
time and I was like what he doing he's
like enjoying freedom what's up a like
it was [ __ ] crazy dog crazy cuz last
time you were in how long were you in
for three years three [ __ ] years yeah
three years right after we filmed by
also comedy slam asleep film payaso
comedy slam what 2006 2006 I went in
June I went in on Filipe his birthday I
think it's uh when's his birthday June
11th yeah June 11th and yeah I week I'm
gonna talk about 2006 if I tell you
where my head was at when I shot that
special I remember you were furious that
you were there early no you would not
know I was a furious I was there early
you're a little overweight to learn I
was overweight I was just furious about
life yeah I'm gonna wish that you know
that's why I told you in the beginning
of this that being cabin odd is not fair
you can't come at somebody except if
they raped you
yeah they physically put a pipe to your
head or something like that because your
character
has changed when I did the payoff so
comedy slam this is how [ __ ] up life
is that you work your whole life for a
goal and somebody comes up to you with a
major opportunity that you found upon
like I found the pound Scott and I hold
and I call him like a man with an L I
called him like a minute cuz that's how
I was raised
yep I found the poem that opportunity
you know how much I prepared for my
hands on comedy slam zero damn zero I
didn't care about family at that time in
2006 and it's dark huh it was a really
dark time I had done The Longest Yard
and nothing had happened
yeah a lot of people had told me that
stuff was gonna happen
so when nothing happened he took me down
we shot that either the night before
Thanksgiving yeah I was the night before
Thanksgiving it was the night before
Thanksgiving they gave us but they gave
me $2,000 to piss me off because they
gave me a check you know like I was one
of those guys like I got pissed off
because the guy gave me a check god
forbid I couldn't buy cocaine can I
forbid I gotta stop at Whitley
check-cashing place catch this man like
yeah lose 80 bucks while I think about
the mindset in 11 years that when I shot
that I was a month or two away from not
knowing where I was gonna go like at
that point I was thinking about breaking
up with my wife damn I was thinking
about going back to the crime life
nothing had happened
that's it I had done a few movies had
done a few TV shows and you know what
these people don't want then they were
gonna get the feeling you get in your
head because yes your Adam Sandler Terry
Crews yeah that was great that
opportunity was fantastic but everybody
else what happened when I first got here
would do half those movies and their
skyrocket success yeah would be
phenomenal you know [ __ ] Tracy Morgan
got the show with the chick [ __ ] Terry
Crews got a bunch of [ __ ] mhmmm
everybody got should accept me and low
blow
who's that Lobo was the guy who played
the linebacker that smoked cigarettes he
got sons a hanneke oh yeah he got two or
three up and they cut his head off and I
ain't no happy ending and the [ __ ] did
not you know you and I was already
economic for 15 years hmm I was already
doing comedy 14 years I had done
spider-man 2 taxi I did a road movie My
Name Is Earl no no no now I just did
them [ __ ] I had him Sam a movie and I
still can't get an agent I still can't
get signed I still can't get a fee I
couldn't get a [ __ ] theatrical agent
like I had like a C [ __ ] agent I went
to innovate it I went to all these
agencies that were like the B ones all
of them turned me down this is what a
[ __ ] real that started with De Niro
killing me at a bar with you know with
[ __ ] knife anyone poly I had some
great fun real MADtv had a phenomenal
reel it's 2006 The Longest Yard was out
of year and it's killing had nothing
happened I got a call for this I got a
call for that and I shot something else
but what people boo the smoke up my ass
nothing happened
dictature did a movie with Tracy Morgan
from that everybody did something from
then except me you know bad I was
feeling I was pretty I was feeling
[ __ ] shitty so I had already done
comedy 14 years I did everything you I
did MADtv which is a comedy yeah bang
and I did this movie without in Sam
and I'm still not going to Montreal they
still not asked me if my the HBO special
I'm still not I've been on picture me if
any improv yeah you know it's time like
what am i doing like I did every hurdle
they put in front of me but now they
don't want to do that what I was a
[ __ ] bad
bro I would buy a package of coke at
eight I would go to the store I would
get on stage to snort it and then I
couldn't lie I didn't want the drug
dealers to know how much coke I was
doing so I had to wait till two to a
bartender got off his name was Johnny
what still make him buy a four you know
I would think I would I would have him
do ever after - I had a black guy I had
a Mexican guy no compadre and had a mess
and got it so coke on the street on
Austin Boulevard on Sunset if you just
pull up at the car - like he'll come up
to you and give you a blast a Mexican
guy he look like my dog it was the
craziest thing when I couldn't when I
couldn't find coke anywhere else all I
had to do was turn the car on three all
the western pulling to the McDonald's
make a u-turn and just park your car
there for a minute and once I went back
on sunset I was going southern with the
light turn red and also you see him come
down from the tree come over me dog
I met him like a year early in that
neighborhood one night like that monkey
am i coming back from a gig with coke in
my power I had money in my pocket and in
those days I would get lost and call
headward there's no they closed the
roads then everyone grew up here so I
won't ever go ahead when they just
closed the one the 105 what do I do
and one night I had to come home off the
- so I went through side came off in
Silver Lake like by flies they used to
live and as I won on Sunset I lose on
Schrader
dunk that's how I met this guy as a
light we made eye contact like he was
standing there like we shirt on
flip-flops like it was summertime
he was out there sweatin it was like
1:00 in the morning and I was headed to
cop and he was just like I'm the thing
looking at me from the bus what you want
to do and I asked him what's going on
and I pulled though I bribed just pulled
over he came over to the driver's side
and in Spanish he asked when I was
looking for I told him that Eko that's
it he asked me if I could he didn't even
asked me if I was a cop he went in his
hand and he crushed something up and he
put it in my nose so I couldn't even
have a check
yeah if I was a carpenter I give him the
amount of money and he just put the coke
rock in my hand and I drive home like
the Domino's pizza guy rock in my hand
before would melt and [ __ ] so I had a
couple different connects I was the
tired place Jorge so I'm back now
oh my god is tripping out on it myself I
hated being here I was getting ready to
leave the store my god like I left the
store in 2007 around there mm-hmm
and I'd already my mind was already made
up I had to get out I had the surgery on
my neck
for the fat ball they took out yeah so I
thought that there was bad spirits at
the store I was [ __ ] up guys I was far
bro I was [ __ ] up and it's God called
you on this and who who eats you up to
Dubai [ __ ] Scott called me and said
he wanted to pay off so at that time I
thought Scott was a [ __ ] Picasso
yes that was a [ __ ] joke but Marilyn
was on a two-seater was eyelid Marilyn
got me bless her soul
yeah all right P Milan Martinez was who
for for me to get me on there and if you
look at the tape like those jeans look
at them they're $10 jeans I had combat
boots on the black shirt was stained on
it I was just a [ __ ] mess you know I
was really really really a physical and
mental mess like I got you out of it
dawg I don't know you
it was like a slow you you in rent I
don't know dawg I've reinvented myself
but it's still me what I feel like I I
don't know dog you've always I remember
you podcast at first for all of us from
what I know and I it's just you're going
dog your people know you it's going no
no Brogan did it and then idea Felicia
no no but it wasn't like that I'm just
thinking about how you really really
really get yourself sometimes I don't I
was in a really dark place that wasn't
suicidal
I wasn't like I was going to kill myself
I just
I had to make a move in 2006 I was I was
43 years old now in 2006 I wasn't no
young kid no more nothing was really
happening for me bro I was I was getting
spots at the store I was 29 that's it
I was just getting spots at the store
nothing was really happening for me I
got these movies I wasn't very much well
liked you know I'm a Montreal telling me
that they didn't like the movement in my
hand but I created my own problems acne
you know I'm saying let's not let's not
blame society in my head and my coked
out mind I would created this [ __ ]
wall there's a there's a tape but if you
really want to see how bad I was you
asked red man you call red Bentley you
go red man email me the link to the Joe
show when Joe was talking that had to be
around that time yeah that that had to
be around January of 2007 when we did
the Joe show and I was going to Vegas
bro
I would get to Vegas with Joe on
Thursday get off the plane we would do a
show on Friday into the UFC on Saturday
Doug Joe and those guys to go eat
Thursday we go eat after that I wouldn't
see him till Sunday on the plane Wow
I had a guy in Vegas who at the time the
UFC's were big this is 2006 I had a guy
in Vegas that you know how you have to
get a key to go upstairs you could just
knock on your door you call him no and
we're all the hotel security
he paid of 8/2 all the securities so he
would bring me [ __ ] coke and vicodins
that's a crazy mixture right there and
bro I would start eating the rice it was
like two or three or four or five I
don't know what I was eating and they
don't make you know better either they
take you into a dark [ __ ] rocky I
smoked him on a blunt once all
Children's yeah Jesus Christ no no no
but I would get talk I was in the dark I
don't know I think I got when I got the
two cats
got Demi and Harry Demi started making
me laugh yeah I had this kitten that
would go home and I'd play with this
kitten and then Wow by June of 2007 I
knew something had happened so I signed
up in that little rehab on Sunset Strip
under a fake name okay I went to a
couple meetings and I tried it out but I
couldn't pull it off bro somebody said
to me one you know long as you are like
Mickey Rourke in the wrestlers cutted me
yeah yeah yeah he cut his arm and she
ran on butts in the chimp it was just a
horrible [ __ ] one my head was that uh
I started doing heroin [ __ ]
that's that's that was just yeah young
I'm telling you you have no idea how
lucky we are to be having a conversation
Hillary I know because like I remember
shoot pay off so I did not want to be
there at all it was like it was an
inconvenience to finally do something
that I wanted to do that's how I stood
and the men I know what you mean you're
like you've been wanting to do this [ __ ]
and you're in this mall all your life
yeah and now I give it to you and now
you don't want to do it now you're
[ __ ] bitching I didn't stay in the
hotel I gave it two days yeah they gave
us like champagne and something else I
gave it away all I wanted was the money
and I wanted to get the [ __ ] out of it
yeah that was it I didn't care about the
art I didn't care about anything if you
look at the set it's a [ __ ] Horror
Show
yeah and all I was looking for was the
light because that light meant the big
coke Rock yeah when that light came up I
wasn't doing like people who run the
light you ain't gonna see me running the
light I never forget getting that check
I'm like they're like we're having an
after-party me going to meet you hard
and dong I got in that [ __ ] car and
I'm in them calling me like where are
you and I saw that sign like 19 miles
with my life and I was like I'm already
and Dave said to me dawg you didn't give
me the key for your hotel room for him
in Maryland cuz yeah a big
with some [ __ ] where he called me and
said that they got on Showtime I can't
tell you how bad I felt cuz you didn't
give it your all on your phone I'm gonna
tell you how bad I felt damn I thought
you did good dog I knew that they had a
bro I was bombed those people were pure
Mexicans that didn't have a sense of
humor I seen them laughing dog there was
some like yeah oh because they like they
like Alex Raymundo it would be a night
with Jose mundo were flicking your head
like a pic he was shot you know I feel
you on that about there like a [ __ ]
Adam Savage [ __ ] and sucking and they
were frozen did we do two shows I'm
getting two shows and shows we didn't
settle down now they were taking people
off the street it was embarrassing from
the first show them to stay on the set
yeah they asked him to stay for the
second it's just you know it just it
just wasn't what I expected it to be and
then the smack in the face was the
reality the call from him going and got
picked up got picked up and after they
gave him one I didn't want to be
interviews like if they kept begging me
when you do interview no I don't want to
have no part of it because I had done so
many of those at that point that I was
sick and time again my father yeah I had
done so many Latino pilots at that time
which so many different member doing
Latino pile in San Antonio what the back
was a castle the Latins you know the
Latin Squires of comedy I did the
Spanish Kings of Comedy
I did 20 of those powers just for the
paycheck that was keeping you I never
went anywhere what's the kid that books
the room close by answer nice kid looks
like De La Hoya for years you do
doughnut hole you impersonate huh huh
sweet kid you know the money ain't gonna
get rich with him yeah he used to book a
room I don't know I'll never forget like
in 2005 after I shot The Longest Yard he
had 20 cameras at the ha he paid me 800
flat again
father deal was what time when we shoot
7:15 I want to be out of there by 7:30
yeah you do you'll do it like oh yeah
800 bucks do you know that that fool
still calls me once every six months is
this a mint
we just got good news Telemundo might
pick it up on my dog that was ten years
ago
nobody wants us who the [ __ ] is this
person I want to know it now and he got
a financier you got like a drug dealer
oh sure they built the set at the haha
the drug dealer Sal I got a throne with
a three fat ugly Mexican [ __ ] that
would have been beat up a thousand times
their feet was busted you could tell
that they will fail they even failed to
being hos like that
I'm not kidding you I know what you mean
yeah I'm not [ __ ] kidding you the
headline that was Gilbert oh she is with
the yellow suit on and the preacher
Bible like it was on like I shot so many
of those things uh I shower with Carlos
Oscar I shower when they came to me this
I couldn't be dirty what's the one we
shout for Jeff Valdez the first one
first my shot with Jeff out there you
know comedy festival what's he know
common I shot everything that was a
weird one I remember Willy hosted that
one then we shot the one at the Ice
House for the other guy talked and
locals local Carlos am so either way
locals made it already locals made it so
I'm like 22 of them that I shot three of
them made it so you just assumed
everyone was gonna fail
yeah at that point everybody kept lying
to me how would you feel if there's a
time you don't know either right you
don't know you're hoping that and then
they tell you a story like yeah it's
your waist gonna be there then you blow
the room up and you're waiting for your
real now wait till you get one of those
leaks yeah I don't even give you wait
till you got a movie and you want your
reel they're like what you have to wait
for the movie gets released okay and
then once the movie get released you
like can I get a reel
you have to wake it the doors the DVD
and you're like what the [ __ ] you know
many of those things I did that I got
the real from zero after you shoot it
they just stop on it because none of
them were junk dealer induced telling
those things we were just talking about
why there were porno me Sam Tripoli
Jason what's his name Oh Tebow
okay Duncan and what about that movie
you did with Felipe well you're like
this sheriff oh my god how bad was that
I don't know like where were you in that
time in life were you all crazy coked
out or oh yeah
cuz you look like a crazy [ __ ] cop in
that [ __ ] look what see what my indeed
be I think I was clean by that time all
right
I think I was making the transition
maybe maybe not unless you're that move
was called a departed then the other
depart if [ __ ] director had the worst
wig you had ever seen and I got a B on
the city I'm no genius I got looked back
in the seventh grade I'm a Cuban that
cannot play baseball so I can not judge
anybody this guy was the worst [ __ ]
director I ever worked with in all my
life was addicted to real special you
got these Filipino investors they're
gonna invest in the Filipe based bars is
moving huh yeah
what's the name of that movie that
Philippe did I'm not like that no more
don't like that no more so look at the
departed the part of them IMDB where'd
you hear was I'm just saying two
thousand six one thousand seven deported
the deported that was important the
deported it's not mine BB Oh night
although yeah I was clean okay I was
cleaning so by that yeah but that movie
was you know these are movies let's just
shoot them you'd listen I talked with
shop I don't even think would make it
either but that's the problem that you
have like my shots by the man to I knew
it was there that it was there when I
shot bass ketball I didn't think I was
gonna make the cut no no because I
didn't know what I was doing
what about grudge match I knew I was
gonna make the cut
okay I have to but then there's movies
in I'm not talking about a studio movie
I'm talking about a movie that you shoot
that people tell you like an independent
film okay like last night the guy the
host at the Comedy Store told the story
about he got hired as a transsexual as a
[ __ ] and the thing in the movie and it
was funny when I went back that go I
gotta tell you what happened to me right
after the sign thought all the signs
thought the rioters got huge deals
do you were a writer on Seinfeld you got
a huge deal and there was just one guy
nope I'm not insulting him but I'm just
breaking it down so we knows the type of
guy I'm talking about he was Jewish but
he was quite privileged Jim yeah
he had become whitey and forgotten his
roots and he was trying to talk all that
Hollywood [ __ ] and he should wanna
shoot a TV pilot for NBC they paved me
NBC rates and everything they paid they
didn't give me great money but they gave
me okay money and to be honest with you
it was the office like I can't tell you
how many things I've shot that two years
later it became huge we were just two
years ahead of its time
okay well they missed a detail or
something happened the showrunner didn't
do good or something happened this was a
pretty good show about an office I
forget who the stars were they called me
in to an early shoot and they shot me
out real quick that was part of the deal
when they when they booked the deal that
there wasn't gonna be any overt desire
that they wanted me to understand is
gonna be a 6:00 a.m. shooting and be out
of there by 9:00 and they shot at CBS
Radford and it was the original office
and for the one day for somebody's
birthday that the original scene was
that I came in with a pair underwear and
that they hit me with a cake in the face
all right now if I wasn't coked out I
would have never done that you know yeah
but it paid like $3,000 just tomorrow
yeah plus I gave a [ __ ] about insurance
and sag from I always were always
worried about sag insurance you gotta
make a certain amount of that they won't
[ __ ] okay so when I booked it like
them when I went to wardrobe to try on
the underwear the writer the white the
Jew that become a white privilege guy
said you know it would be very funny if
you put makeup on and did this and I'm
[ __ ] fuming I might know what I don't
know like dressing up like a woman like
that [ __ ] yeah I don't one of those guys
are they funny to me I don't play the
guy plays a dress and comes out that
don't even though that dude special was
very
I forget what his name was what he do or
address but after the first minute the
shock is gone and you gotta wear a dress
yeah it's like wearing a [ __ ] Viking
shirt to a Raider game you know you
[ __ ] you gotta wear that shirt home
yeah
so I argued I had a [ __ ] agent I told my
agent I really wanted to do it then they
just gave me an ultimatum
they said he dresses up Oh we'll find
somebody else and it was you know it was
true they shot in two hours but it was
one of those things that they dressed me
up like a [ __ ] with underwear on in
high heels and they can't hit me in the
face with a pie we were fine after the
[ __ ] fourth shot I hadn't liked call
time out though I hope you guys got it
cuz I'm done I got it's like I was the
bad [ __ ] here you ready to start [ __ ]
it blah it was like mm two or three was
like in your face daughter like toss no
in my face uh-huh
there was like four inches of cake with
tons of whipped cream and they had like
20 cakes and after the fourth take
that's a guy's pitch over and they're
like no I go listen that's it like I
muscled them like the [ __ ] Chinese
did to the Mafia I go it's over and they
knew I mind doing it again guys got it
yeah that's it and they cut it and they
kept calling me bro every two months bro
we're gonna get picked up and I'm at
home cutting chicken heads off I'm doing
everything I can for this show not to
get picked even though I was gonna recur
in the [ __ ] show it like 9,500 a week
your son because before I shoot the
pilot they tell you they're gonna return
and they'll give you then tell they're
gonna pay me ninety two hundred a week
Oh every week I was going to do a
different stunts that's a fat dude I
don't want to do that I just did it one
time just to get my head together and
that's what I was doing I was making bad
choices just because of the coke problem
actually I wanted by the time I shot
payaso I was just sick and tired of
hearing Showtime HBO
I shot bro if I tell you how many HBO
specials I shot and how many ad you'd be
like floored like if I went home and
counted them and went through my books I
gotta say I shot seven
HBO specials with three or four other
comics Wow and I got picked a tall one
in Fresno we shot with this black dude
he had a brother as [ __ ] he's be up my
brother's gonna hook me up his [ __ ] he's
friends with Tito Jackson you know those
people one of those guys that the check
was like they tried to put you in a
hotel room with somebody else and yeah I
step up to the plate my bad I didn't
know you know I didn't know you did
everybody knows they don't wanna [ __ ]
you know I get all of them so that was
my problem with the I saw that I was
just sick and tired man yeah it was my
first ever oh you you guys were excited
and I was excited to be there but deep
down inside what I was going through was
such [ __ ] misery lock deep down
inside I was miserable because my comedy
wasn't working the coke and the pills
weren't helping my relationship at home
was kind of starting to slip I was
losing contact with her in a way because
yeah disgust - that hurt that you play
yeah it was it was like I'm not doing
this poor girl anything yeah it's like
you said when you're all cooked out you
look in the mirror and you really see
yourself it's scary it's scary man and
[ __ ] imagine that [ __ ] Lee looking at
yourself and yourself is telling you a
dog you have black eyes you're oh it's
[ __ ] scary you're unhealthy so back
to the question yes
did you change in the last 20 years do
you think that you changed as a man I've
completely changed as a man and like I
could see it now like I've become a good
[ __ ] great father I'm more responsive
relationship with its dude my kid my
oldest son lives with me my 19 year old
he's he's doing things and that we
always hey I talk to my kids that is
every other day or like I go visit them
me and my daughter are real close it's a
bro it's like super continuous action I
see you look good you look healthy thank
you yeah doc I'm gonna see you doing
spots and it's crazy how you know people
I got an opportunity now you know I got
to snap first thing coming
that's my boy opportunity and again I
feel like you know I didn't do the job
but it doesn't matter I'm proud that
Netflix gave me the opportunity and
hopefully I'm gonna put this note this
total rat tour together and I'm gonna
use all you guys thank you know people
reach out to me like that like what I'm
gonna get too close to her vine I start
getting those weird emails whenever you
do her vine Brea yeah I'll tell you get
those long-lost brothers that call you
that yeah and it bothers me because if
they would have kept in contact with me
maybe always but they just come up and
meet you it's um - [ __ ] me I like
helping the people around me that I see
making moves people people Jesus helps
those who help themselves
I've always believed I got a C I'm gonna
see it you know there's people call me
I'm like dog you gotta come to my
Facebook and [ __ ]
come to my podcast first thing I do is
get off the phone and check their
[ __ ] media stuff yeah if I don't see
no podcast [ __ ] you're wasting my free
apps this is an hour to go down there
and how would I do it my straight out I
can't do it I can't there's a lot you
know I have a kid now I gotta be there
at 2:20 my day there ends at 2:20 or at
3:45 yeah I don't have the time I used
to know more that's it tomorrow at 2:20
I gotta pick her up tomorrow that's a
wrap that's a wrap
that's the podcast rethinks I do or
meeting there's that my days done that's
why I got a walk one at 6:00 in the
[ __ ] morning at 6:00 in the morning
I'm walking around writing stupid [ __ ]
making notes if I go to a coffee shop
and catch a breakfast and write notes
there I try to work out you always got
to do you gotta take care yourself you
gotta work out a little bit and then
boom I pick her up and then I have a
little grace time in between and then
afterward before my spot or another
podcast but I'm always [ __ ] moving
yeah
I never that's why that whole cabin door
thing pissed me off and I wanted to talk
to somebody who had been locked up and
who was honest and somebody was very
honest so if it looked me in the eye and
so I'm like I don't understand you
cannot if I did something of criminal
intent to you that is a criminal charge
and it's still under whatever you could
still do your thing but you can't come
at me now and say it in high school
I got some [ __ ] up [ __ ] I covered your
mouth that started scaring me for a
while yeah I didn't cover no woman's
mouth and I'm like that but to that you
got to sit there and say one of the
somebody gonna come on go I did this I'm
waiting for something to come on and say
I robbed them yeah oh this is episode
228 I told the story the podcast myself
yeah we used to play this game like like
you know how you goes fried
you know you ghost ride your bike yeah
we used to do ghost ride the backseat
where you just finger bang thank you if
we win they win it sometime this girl
just grabbed my hand and made me go to
town like they knew I'm like what's up
you guys down I'm like you guys
difficult for girls right finger-banged
is my [ __ ] so they don't fix it in
the back through the car and you can't
turn around and you just got to drive
and try to get it in in front of me I
can see that money like I see the look
on their face I gotta be thinking
somebody backwards put that pressure on
my elbow I'm like a tennis elbow from
finger the [ __ ] that's what I need can
you imagine I did you get tennis up I
was fingering the chick backwards the
[ __ ] is wrong with these people
we're going to Cleveland [ __ ] Thursday
oh yeah ready to go we got one shot
Thursday to Friday to Saturday George
I'm very proud of your success and
brings on a change that you made and I'm
happy you made it on this show I wanna
wish everybody a happy [ __ ] Monday it
sure we grab your balls part of your
balls whatever you need to do last week
was last week this week is this week I
want to thank George I want to thank the
[ __ ] [ __ ] you the fine Jews been
silent tonight I want to thank your boy
give a shout-out to his company that's
our business woods bzzt woods they got
the best blunts pre-rolled glass targets
you can see him I'm [ __ ] Instagram and
everything he's got in his stores right
yeah yeah okay and we'll see him out
there thank you all right I want to
thank George Perez I want to thank the
Flying Jew but most importantly I want
to thank you guys hold on one second
listen watching football is fun but it's
more entertaining when you got action on
the games all right
whether it's hoops college hoops
haki that's coming guys you've heard me
talking about this for weeks and some of
you are still sitting on the sidelines
like a Mook waiting for somebody to
knock on your door whether you're an
expert or a rookie you should be betting
at my bookie if you're the kind of guy
that likes to bet a little to win a lot
like playing the numbers on the roulette
you can create a huge parlay they
understand you pick three teams to win
and if you hit all three of them you
turn a large stick allows in to $600
there's so much to bet on playoff base I
mean what plant World Series baseball
basketball hockey
I mean it's endless you can be a action
every night but my bookies one bet I
know you'll be happy with all year I
recommend these guys because I trust
them
my bookie has been in business for years
you understand me years they got great
online reviews and their mobile site is
easy to use my book is offering a 100%
bonus for the last time this year that's
right 100% when you talking about Joey
100% bonus have you been thinking about
place in a pickoff season but you
haven't manned up yet well it's time to
make your move after Sunday's kickoff
you can kiss that bonus money goodbye
and also make sure to follow bet my
bookie on Twitter and Instagram
they'll personally respond to every
mention and DM not to mention they'll
give you their giving away nearly 10,000
free money to their followers this
football season so but you'll be the
first to know as soon as the new odds
and the props are posted how's that be
it so do me a favor you know where Joey
comes in straight log on to my bookie
right now log on to my bookie right now
and don't miss out on your last
opportunity to collect the industry's
biggest bonus use promo code Church you
know why you'll get your first deposit
match and a hundred percent that's a
hundred percent use promo code Church
you play you win you get paid that's my
bookie the church is also brought to you
by my favorite supplement country
company in the world okay
they got great kettlebells they got
clubs you know or breeze you're doing a
great job down there I just did a video
for my little workout with the club
bells and my little kettlebell workout
if you're over 50 listen on is the way
to go from the the whey protein shake
that
the Mexican chocolate to the alpha brain
to the shroom tech immune to the shrimp
export I live off that stuff you know I
live on planes guys you go on a plane
they're filthy people breathing people
feed out I take a to those and meals I
walk off the plane coughing like I just
ate somebody's monkey you understand me
go to out a.com right now press in
church and get 10% off the liver right
the house you didn't have to leave the
house get some alpha brain in your life
give it a shot you've been a little
[ __ ] robots lately listen if you
around a lot of people all day you want
to take the shroom check immune if you
want a little boost in your performance
take the shroom tech sport it's got the
the mushrooms from up in the valley they
spread out in your lungs I have no
[ __ ] idea so I look like a [ __ ]
scientist here but I love on it they did
great they're solid people and get the
apps and the supplements are tremendous
I got only get you 10% off on the
supplements nothing on the weight side
so go down at that come right now
impress in church all right don't forget
Thursday through Sunday me and George
Perez rockin it and [ __ ] Cleveland
elaborate ease I'm ready to [ __ ] go
already a friar Flyman slime and
whatever the [ __ ] it is on Friday and
tear into a pastrami sandwich alright
and then in two weeks November 8th me
KEK Quigley kick off the New York Comedy
Festival grand got them on a Thursday
night or I tickets are available you
know I love you [ __ ] Lisa at my
little brother always here and I'm gonna
thank George Perez have a great [ __ ]
Monday tell them all to suck your dick
that uncle Joey sent you check this
[ __ ] mealy